I do not consider that there is any
purpose in deferring sentence
as the pre-sentence report makes clear
you are not someone who needs
Rehabilitation you need to be sentenced
and then both you and the family of
Harry Dunn can move on
if I were to impose an immediate
custodial sentence then you would be
unlawfully at large thereafter and I
would order you to return to the United
Kingdom to serve it the sentence will be
put into effect if and when you enter
the jurisdiction and surrendered to a
police station
before doing so I have considered
whether it is possible to suspend the
sentence
you have the strong personal mitigation
I have already summarized
you are also a mother of young children
who would suffer disproportionate harm
from your immediate imprisonment and I
am satisfied that appropriate punishment
can be achieved without immediate
custody
please stand up Mrs sakulas
you are disqualified from driving for 12
months
for the offense of causing the death of
Harry Dunn by your careless driving the
sentence is eight months imprisonment
suspended for 12 months
there will be no additional requirements
the sentence means that if in the next
12 months you commit any offense whether
or not it is of the same type for which
I am sentencing you today you would find
yourself before the court again
and it is likely that the sentence will
be brought into operation either in full
or in part
thank you very much you may sit down